this video is brought to you by surf
shark VPN whatsup wisecrack jared here
to talk about one of the dummer
conspiracy theories we've ever come
across the idea that 5g has caused the
global pandemic known as cove at 19 and
while these desperate times are full of
snake oil salesmen this one perhaps
takes the cake
meet Thomas Cowan Thomas's video
claiming that 5g causes Cove in nineteen
had over half a million views on YouTube
before being taken down and that idea
with the help of celebrities like woody
harrelson is gaining traction in the UK
people have torched several 5g towers
for its alleged role in the pandemic the
UK has reported around 50 fires
targeting towers and other 5g equipment
of course this is all bonkers and we'll
get to that but we nonetheless wanted to
dive deep into what exactly these people
are saying and why because the line
between science and non science is not
as easy to discern as one might think so
how can we tell the difference let's
find out welcome to this wisecrack
edition on the anatomy of pseudoscience
but before we get into it I want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor surf
shark VPN a VPN is a virtual private
network a tool that can be used to
connect to the internet securely when
you connect to the internet with a VPN
your IP address and other valuable data
are encrypted protecting you against
hackers this means you can safely use
your banking info without fear of a
leaked pin surf shark goes above and
beyond your typical VPN by offering
extra services like kill switch which
disables your internet connection when
your VPN stops working so you're always
protected they also offer an ad and
cookie blocker so the sites can't
collect data or target you with ads the
best part about surf shark is that you
only need one subscription to connect to
an unlimited amount of devices you can
connect on your computer phone iPad or
even your gaming console protect
yourself online and download surf shark
VPN today click the link in the
description and use the promo code
wisecrack to get eighty five percent off
your subscription plus three months free
and now back to the show let's get back
to Thomas his pitch is simple when
ourselves get sick they excrete toxins
and 5g is poisoning those cells causing
them to poop out his words it's the body
is pooping out poisons it's obviously
not good to eat other people's poop
toxins that make us sick with a little
thing called kovat 19 in his many
YouTube videos he makes a series of
incredible claims they include viruses
don't cause diseases the Spanish flu
that killed tens of millions was caused
by the electrification of the earth and
radio waves because we're electrical
beings other major outbreaks in the last
century were caused by said
electrification also he's an anti-vaxxer
obviously the most outlandish part about
this is how technology has caused all
these infectious diseases especially
given the many fun and exciting
infectious diseases that were among the
leading causes of death pre electricity
like smallpox bubonic plague or the
measles to be fair proving diseases
existed before radio doesn't prove
radios can't make us sick but Cowens
entire worldview seems to be natural
equals good like when he talks about all
the pure water we used to drink there
was no toxic stuff dissolved in the
water and conveniently forgets the
thousands of years people would drop
dead of drinking water teeming with
pathogens from your upstream neighbors
you might be asking how do people fall
for this you might respond they're
stupid but I think this excuse is lazy
plenty of smart and thoughtful people
fall for pseudo scientific nonsense and
you probably will at some point in your
life do the same pseudo science often
looks like real science experts will be
trotted out MDS PhDs from real
universities they'll even have evidence
and studies for one of the most
interesting things about pseudoscience
is the use and abuse of this evidence
and the basic problem of context so
let's talk about context there's one
pretty illustrative example from
Netflix's goop series in one episode an
energy healer insists that his 100% not
scientifically backed energy healing
process of waving his hands over your
body really does work by using a rock
solid piece of evidence the double-slit
experiment one foundational study is
called the double slit experiment proved
empirically without a shadow of a doubt
that our consciousness actually shifts
or alters in some way shape or form too
reality you might remember this
experiment mentioned in high school or
college physics but the takeaway is this
light can act like a particle or wave
but if observed it will collapse into
its particle state that this proves our
mind can affect the material world is
well not completely bogus but so vague
that it could be construed to mean
anything our consciousness affects
physical reality all the time as it
instructs my palm to cover my face in
complete disbelief that Netflix aired
this show she threw up from 3 a.m. to 4
a.m. but sadness aside such a claim
relies on a few things one a
misunderstanding of the context of the
experiment light collapses into a single
stage because it has to interact with
the measuring tool observing it not
because our consciousness willed it to
be so to a large interpretive leap that
goes above and beyond the extremely
limited hypothesis that the experiment
is testing cue the science explaining
text on screen and the use of the word
implies let's just say you could will
light to be a particle or wave by
thinking it does an experiment that
proves this mean you can make weird
puppet gestures to cure people's
ailments No the basic problem is this
pseudo science often preys on the fact
that victims are educated for instance
anti-vaxxers tend to be more educated
than their well vaccinated peers we all
can't be quantum theory experts or
immunologists so instead they give us
evidence that often conforms to our
basic understanding of science so when
energy healing man explains the energy
that runs through our muscles it seems
to vaguely sound like our understanding
of anatomy you have energy that's bound
up in the muscles and ligaments and
spine and facha
and organs when you're under stress then
they stretch the applicability of that
evidence by making huge logical leaps
based on the evidence they present
crystals vibrates at different levels
depending on their composition and color
as
the cells in the human body the success
of pseudoscience praise not on the fact
that people are dumb but now we are
completely incapable of knowing every
scientific principle that intersects
with our lives I have a headache I take
a Tylenol but I personally have zero
idea how the biochemistry involved makes
it better with that in mind let's get
into the profound lack of context
implicit in the idea that it isn't
viruses that cause kovat 19 but 5g will
have to start with the question how do
we know what viruses cause what
illnesses before the 1800s people had
basically no idea what was making most
people sick sure they had some theories
but it wasn't until the 17 and 1800s
that a series of discoveries vastly
expanded our knowledge of the microbial
world that was killing us you probably
remember Louis Pasteur as the guy that
discovered heating up milk would make
sure your cow juice wouldn't murder you
but his experiments helped the formation
of the germ theory of disease notably
Pasteur had a rival named Robert Koch
who was also looking into the tiny
murderous world around us cokes work in
microbiology is the entire reason why we
know when you've got say the flu instead
of kovat and it's Robert Koch who Cowan
cites to support his claims that Cova 19
isn't caused by a virus Koch and his
peers were faced with a question how
exactly does a scientist determine of
all the millions of organisms in our
body which one is making us sick Koch
had four simple rules known as Koch's
postulates one we can suspect a specific
microorganism of causing an illness if
we can find that organism in all the
cases of that illness but that's not
enough because there are many different
microorganisms in all of our bodies
which brings us to two you have to be
able to isolate this microorganism and
grow it in a pure culture let's say
you've got someone suffering from Cova
19 you can take a nasal sample and
filter out the other organisms and grow
some disease juice in a petri dish 3 the
cultured microbe will cause disease in a
healthy host now modern scientists often
don't want to intentionally make people
sick with their ethics and all so
instead they might introduce their
disease juice to some healthy lab cells
or sadly a monkey rat or some other
animal and see if they develop Kogut 19
symptoms
for your able to watch as your newly
infected organism produces enough virus
or bacteria for you to once again
isolated in a petri dish making a brand
new batch of disease juice and in line
with making logical leaps from real
science Cowen uses Koch's postulates as
a reason to explain why kovat and the
flu are hoaxes for one he claims that in
Boston during the Spanish flu they
sucked the snot out of people and
injected it into healthy people
eliciting no symptoms that would make it
disqualified by cokes third postulate
except well we looked at that paper and
the author pretty much says I'm pretty
sure we're doing everything wrong
ironically the whole reason people found
the virus that caused the flu was Koch's
postulates unsure of what was causing
everyone to get sick with the Spanish
flu some suspected a bacteria called
Pfeiffer's bacillus while others
suspected a specific virus importantly
bacteria are much larger than viruses so
they can be filtered out with tiny
little virus sized holds true to coax
postulate in 1918 two French researchers
were able to infect monkeys and a human
with their isolated bacteria free virus
Jews who subsequently got sick thus
giving strong evidence that the flu was
caused by the influenza virus
instead of Pfeiffer's bacillus
additionally other researchers helped to
rule out Pfeiffer's bacillus because
they found it in all kinds of people
without the flu thus violating cokes
first postulate it's important to note
how these findings come about because of
a community of scientists and not a lone
study or researcher Koch's postulates
were not only critical 100 years ago
they're critical today when researchers
in Korea wanted to figure out what was
what we now call covert 19 they isolated
a virus that looked a lot like SARS and
infected healthy lab cells to fulfill
part of Koch's postulates that virus
they called SARS Covey's who researchers
have also claimed to successfully infect
monkeys and rats
Koch's postulates are not perfect though
and even he realized this for instance
some people contract infections but
don't show symptoms and while we might
want to say boom Kok debunked there's
plenty of other reasons to believe that
microorganisms are still infectious
without affecting everyone who contracts
them like when a certain irish cook
managed to give typhoid to a bunch of
the families she cooked for despite
being perfect
healthy or how some viruses can go
dormant in our bodies like herpes
before becoming active again scientists
often debate how to best tweak Koch's
postulates modern techniques like
sequencing the genome of a suspected
virus and comparing it to genetically
similar viruses like comparing coded 19
to SARS
can provide evidence for identifying the
microbial causes of an illness not even
dream about in copes time but people
like Cowan playing it fast and loose
with the scientific principles they dish
out will say things like Koch's
postulates assert that 100 percent of
people with the virus or bacteria should
have symptoms an idea that not even Koch
believed and of course there is little
to no experimental evidence that
suggests viruses are just cell poop and
I'm unaware of anyone blasting lab cells
with 5g waves that was able to produce
the novel coronavirus from nothing like
our energy healer Cowen points to real
research to imply that he's correct but
here's our favorite part of the story
Cowen is a medical doctor he went to
medical school he should have the
medical context for why these claims are
completely bonkers but it's also worth
noting most doctors are not research
scientists and their training focuses on
rote memorization not critical thinking
or modern research techniques and this
is at least part of the reason you can
find plenty of people with medical
degrees saying the dumbest things about
vaccines or coronavirus they think
simply being armed with the facts in a
vacuum will lead them to the right
conclusion which brings us to the
problem of evidence we're never really
taught to think critically about
evidence and how it should shape our
understanding of the world to figure out
why let's consider Cowan's evidence
first he claims that 5g was launched in
Bhutan China where kovat originated
aside from the fact that this is just
wrong as 5g services previously existed
in parts of the US and South Korea this
is allegedly correlational evidence as
is a series of pandemics that coincided
with radio and other technology at this
point in the video
countless boards have likely already
commented lol correlation doesn't equal
causation and that's true but
correlation is important evidence
evidence that we use all the time and
the fact that places which have no 5g
are also experiencing kovat outbreaks is
evidence that this specific correlation
is [ __ ] let's turn back to Cowan's
Dunc on how the Boston researchers
couldn't deliberately infect people with
the flu not even with their gross flu
snot this evidence is meant to cast
doubt on the prevailing idea that
viruses are infectious if a virus isn't
giving people the flu then surely
something else must be like the radio
what should we make of all this evidence
one route is just to call it bad
evidence no 5g existed elsewhere before
Wuhan no correlation doesn't equal
causation but there's something else
going on here that we've seen a lot in
people like Cowen energy healers and
flat-earthers
a fetishization of the crucial
experiment if we could simply get one of
these ring laser gyroscope we would be
able to prove once and for all that
there is no rotation to the earth the
crucial experiment was an idea set forth
by Francis Bacon many of you know as the
scientific method guy you've probably
heard a story like this people have some
outdated or wrong idea and someone has a
Eureka moment designing an experiment to
settle the case once and for all
think Newton with his prism proving his
theory of light or if your energy guide
the double slit experiment is the
crucial experiment that proves you can
realign people's energy by snapping
earth and I'm making sounds with my
hands I'm putting energy into the field
around some of these bodies and while
science is full of these important
experiments
the problem with crucial experiments is
that they rarely if ever exist as we
understand them this all speaks to the
basic problem in science known as under
determination which the stanford
encyclopedia of philosophy defines as
the simple idea that the evidence
available to us at a given time may be
insufficient to determine what beliefs
we should hold in response to it this
idea originates from the work of pierre
duhem a French physicist who argues that
when one performs an experiment and
tests a hypothesis there's never one
single hypothesis being tested when one
wants to test the idea that the flu is
infectious one might COFF on a healthy
person to see if they get sick but there
is an innumerable amount of assumptions
and hypotheses embedded in any simple
test for instance that the flu virus
travels via air that it's always present
in a sick person's lung or throat that a
sick person is always infectious that
viruses exist and so on when an
experiment fails deulim argues it's
impossible to say where
the failure lies let's unpack it within
the context of our Boston flu experiment
putting someone's snot into someone's
body rests on all kinds of hypotheses
and assumptions reading the paper has
the author as a good scientist asking
questions about what kind of assumptions
he incorrectly made about the flu does
transporting said mucus for four hours
somehow harm the flu virus for the
people they tried to infect already
exposed without knowing it
two people stopped being contagious even
while they're sick thus the conclusion
that the flu is not infectious was not
even considered by the performer of the
experiment all it really shows was how
little they knew about the flu and viral
infections which would hopefully
encourage scientists to dig deeper and
deeper it's also important to remember
that science happens when people build
conclusions from evidence and
unfortunately this is a prime way human
bias and de mastery can enter the
scientific process and a complete
ignorance of how human bias easily
enters the scientific process has led to
some of Sciences worst mishaps I want to
stress this slam dunk flu evidence from
Cowan because this kind of tactic isn't
just a common refrain for anti-vaxxers
energy healers or the 5g causes kovat
people but almost every talking head
you've seen on television and YouTube
seriously just look at any video with
bones in the title and you'll likely
find some pundit or straight-up quack
offering a handful of key studies that
thoroughly debunk the other side but the
problem is science doesn't work like
this science is not an individual
process where one scientist performs a
crucial experiment and changes the game
it's done with other scientists Louie
Pasteur and Robert Koch would have been
relegated to the dustbin of history if
their ideas about germs weren't built
upon by countless experiments and
theorization of their peers not only
peers who replicated their experiments
but built upon their techniques as they
went looking for microbes developed
vaccines and looked for evidence that
poked holes in their theories even the
French researchers who isolated the flu
virus would have been long forgotten if
their evidence wasn't corroborated and
built upon an entire web of knowledge is
built as historian Naomi Oreskes writes
summarizing Pierre dooms work
experiments simply tell us if a theory
is confirmed or weakened by the fact
next time you see someone touting an
experiment that seemingly up ends
everything we know about one thing or
another ask yourself does it really many
conspiracy theories have a smoking gun
like Andrew Wakefield's discredited
study linking autism to the MMR vaccine
or Cowan's slam dunk of a study from a
hundred years ago if pseudoscience is
appealing because it latches on the
scientific principles that we vaguely
remember from high school the full
context of those principles is what
often makes pseudoscience fall apart
it's the web of knowledge not individual
facts studies or tests that makes
science robust so when Cowan points to
the very basic principles of biology to
disprove the idea that kovat 19 is an
infectious disease it's only the context
of those principles that can save us and
for scientists or esky says it's not
just on them to tell the world what they
know but how they know it there's the
constant refrain and a lot of bad
alarmism that we don't know the effects
of this thing and while plenty of
corporations have put out products that
accidentally killed a bunch of people
the answer is not to invent a cause out
of thin 5g Laden air of course Thomas
Cohen's idea that an untested technology
is dangerous to human health and should
be stopped at all costs it's also
incredibly ironic because his own
medical license was put on probation
after he suggested a patient with breast
cancer take a drug that has never gone
through any safety trials without even
suggesting to the patient it might be
dangerous he also did so without ever
consulting the patient's medical records
or performing an in-person examination
whoops thanks again to all our patrons
for supporting us don't forget to
subscribe and we'll catch you next time
peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]